Another taboo is to celebrate European
culture.
Multiculturalists get pretty unhappy
when Europeans start expressing pride in
their culture or heritage.
Many especially on the left,
do not draw much of a distinction,
at least in practice between European
pride and white supremacy.
You care about freedom of the
individual,
the individual's freedom to think,
to speak,
to associate in short,
to act as he sees fit without external
compulsion,
as long as he doesn't infringe on the
similar liberties of others.
Professor Ricardo do a historical
sociologists and professor at the
University of New Brunswick argues that
quote,
individualism is a unique attribute of
European peoples.
Quote,
it has been exported to some degree to
other nations,
but in my view,
it is not something that comes to them
naturally,
so he continues.
Quote,
you can't play the game of we're all
individuals.
We have to affirm and be proud of our
ethnic identity and heritage to preserve
the West's curious individualism.
If Europeans have become minorities in
the west,
he argues the founding idea of the West,
that no entity,
not an individual,
not a community,
not the state congested.
We deprive an individual of life,
liberty,
or property by force,
no matter what the individual's race,
class or religion.
I wouldn't be surprised if Dushane when
he made this statement,
had you in mind.
Look,
the
medieval Europeans identified seven
deadly sins for reason and one of them
was pride.
It's like,
let's make the presumption.
I do believe that for for reasons that
aren't obvious that the west has got
some things right.
We've got the sovereignty of the
individual,
right?
That's the most fundamental thing we've
got,
right?
We've articulated that I think in a,
in a remarkable way,
not only theologically,
philosophically in her body of laws and
our societies,
and one of the consequences of that as
it's had its effect on the rest of the
world is that everyone is getting richer
quite fast and that's a really good
thing.
Okay.
Having said that,
it's like,
am I proud of that?
It's like,
I didn't do that.
What the hell?
Pride.
What's that?
That's not the right response.
How about responsibility for that?
How would that be?
It's like you're a part of.
This is great.
Okay,
and unlikely set of propositions,
this strange set of propositions that
says that in some ineffable manner,
the poorest person is as valuable as the
king.
It's like,
how the hell did we ever figure that
out?
That's an impossible thing to think and
yet that's the.
That's the bedrock of our legal system.
That's nothing to be proud of.
That's something to tremble before to
take on as an ethical burden and not to
wave a flag for how wonderful you are
that you happen to have the same skin
color as some of the people who thought
that up.
It's not the right response.
It's like it's open your eyes and
recognize that as a miracle and a
relatively relatively new miracle on the
world stage and to and to participate in
the process of upholding that in your
personal and your public life.
That's not pride in European tradition.
Like when I go to Europe and I love
going to Europe and the European cities
are there unbelievable masterpieces,
which is why they're completely flooded
by pilgrims,
right?
Tourists,
pilgrims who go there to look at the
beauty,
so I don't feel pride about that.
I feel,
I feel like I have something to live up
to that's not the same thing,
man,
and so these right wingers in this,
it's like,
look what we've done.
It's like,
no,
it's not you that did that.
That's something mad you gotta you gotTa
have your act together before you would
dare to say,
well,
that was me.
It's like,
yeah,
sure,
sure it was you.
Yeah,
right.
No,
it's hard to stand up and take your
place in that,
in that kind of historical process,
that unlikely,
miraculous historical process,
not to just feel ashamed at the way that
you're presently constituted in the face
of that means that you're diluted and
you're using your,
your your great fortune of being a
beneficiary of that system.
Look at what we've got here,
this great pace that we're inhabiting
right now.
You're using your unearned,
the unearned gift that's been granted to
you as a source of personal pride in
your accomplishments do to your skin.
It's like,
no,
not good.
Not a good argument.
So and that doesn't mean that while
there's nothing valuable about European
culture,
there's plenty.
There's plenty about it that's value.
It's not even so clear to what degree
it's European.
I mean it came out of the Middle East,
you know,
mean who it's so muddle headed that you
hardly know where to start.